hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
among the stoic paradoxes that Cicero
discusses in that book by the same name
that is saying that the Stoics had that
many other people found difficult to
accept because they went against common
belief one of the most interesting ones
has to do with the contrast between
wisdom and foolishness on the one hand
and freedom and slavery on the other
hand the relationship between on the one
hand wisdom and genuine freedom and on
the other hand between slavery and
foolishness now what does he mean by
wisdom and foolishness it's important to
keep in mind that for the Stoics wisdom
an extends to not only a knowledge about
how things are but but the practical
matters understanding what the good is
for human beings how to behave in
circumstances that call for balancing
out different priorities for example and
foolishness likewise is not just a
matter of not knowing certain things
that one ought to but also conducting
the mind poorly foolishness is a vice
wisdom is a virtue developed it within
the person and one of the key things
that that helps you make sense of this
from the start
since rule tells us that freedom here
he's giving you a definition is the
power
potestas right to to live vis nd as you
will as you choose to quite literally as
your will directs Corvalis in the way in
which you you decide to and so who
really enjoys this if we look at what
what many people think is living as you
will it turns out to be something like
partying all the time and drinking or
doing lots of drugs and getting to have
sex with you know people that you meet
at random who happen to have
attractive bodies or are the flavor of
the month or pick whatever else you want
or you know for some people it's you
know getting to shoot guns or go fishing
whenever they want to or pick you know
whatever other hobby go shopping and
spend as much as you like right we can
go on and on and on and out of that in
cicero's time it things like having
offices and and that is also something
that we tend to value success in life
right and one of the things that that
Cicero is going to point out is not only
are the pursuit of those as being the
primary good in life a form of
foolishness those are going to land you
in a kind of slavery it's only the wise
person who actually gets to live the way
that he wants to or she wants to why
well in part because the wise person
actually understands matters is
fundamentally important matters
correctly and they're going to do what
is right so Cicero will say who lives as
he wills except one who follows the
things that actually are right who does
the right thing who delights
who enjoys doing his duty who has a
well-considered path of life map down
from them understand matters correctly
and plans things out who obeys the laws
not because of fear but follows and
respects them because he judges this to
be most conducive to health and to you
know flourishing whose every utterance
in action even thought is voluntary and
free whose enterprises and courses of
conduct takers start from himself and
likewise have there ended himself there
being no other thing that has more
influence with him than his own will and
judgment this is a person who is
genuinely independent autonomous there
are not autonomous in the sense that
they can do anything whatsoever because
if they choose to do the wrong things
they're actually in a cert
sounds destroying that very you know
autonomy that they have that very
freedom that they have and what they're
doing is throwing it away in a certain
sense Cicero will go on and tell us that
the person who is wise in this way the
beautiful phrase does nothing against
his will why because he is restricting
his will to what he can actually
accomplish he does nothing by compulsion
and as Cicero will say he does nothing
in regret it's totally the opposite for
the person who is foolish and one of the
things that is most characteristic of
foolish people tends to be the fact that
they don't actually realize that they
are foolish and Cicero says that by
being foolish they are actually placing
themselves in the the category of being
slaves they are enslaving themselves
they are using the freedom that they
have in the wrong way and thereby
essentially nullifying that freedom so
he goes on and he says you know some
examples that he has are all wicked men
are slaves he says nor is this so
startling a thing as as it sounds we
don't mean that they're slaves in the
sense of chattels that they've become
the property of their Lords for debt or
some law of state but if slavery means
as it does mean he says the obedience of
a broken and abject spirit that has no
volition of its own that can't actually
decide for itself no judgment of its own
no our bit reom right who would deny
that all light-minded and covetous
people and indeed all the vicious people
are really slaves those who are covetous
those who desire all sorts of things
like money or you know fancy houses or
you know decked out cars or having the
best stereo system in the world I don't
know if people do that anymore
but that used to be a big thing back in
the day those are the sorts of things or
you know wonderful clothing and clothing
by distance
Niner if you have that sort of thing is
your main priority in your life you are
in fact subjecting yourself to desires
you become a slave to your own desires
and you have to do whatever is going to
satisfy that desire here's another great
example and I think we can you know
extend this to either gender can I think
a man free who is under the command of a
woman who receives laws from her and
such rules and orders and prohibitions
as she thinks fit who when she commands
can deny her nothing and dares refuse
her nothing she asks he must give she
calls he must come she throws him out he
must go and he goes on and on with some
funny examples the idea is if you know a
romantic relationship is demanding of us
that we have to behave in a certain way
we're in fact becoming a slave within
the framework of that relationship that
doesn't mean that all romantic
relationships thereby become bad you
could have two wise people who actually
understand how human beings ought to
behave in relation to each other based
on what's actually good for human beings
and not what you know Cosmo has said you
ought to do or GQ or Maxim or whatever
nonsense magazine you're relying upon
for your tips on how to treat somebody
who you're dating you know and and he
goes on and on with many other examples
you know one that I'll actually point
out that's particularly good is towards
the end he says is there any doubt about
the slavery of people who are so
covetous of cash they refuse no
condition of the harshest servitude the
hope of a legacy what harshness of
service does it not undertake what not
from a rich old man without children
does it not attend to it makes
conversation when it suits him execute
all those commissions he goes on and on
as well what this was talking about
there is in enrollment times you could
actually if you didn't have children you
could pass on your estate
to somebody else and when you know
people knew that you're in that case
they would try to get adopted by you why
would they try to get adopted by you
because then you would pass on your
legacy and that meant you could make
them jump through any sort of hoops that
you wanted to if you were a good person
of course you wouldn't be doing that but
if you're a bad person well then you
would probably make them grovel and do
all sorts of things for you and dangle
that prize in front of them you would
make them your slaves now in doing so of
course you would become a slave to
something else the desire say for power
something else that he discusses in
there people who are trying to attain
power over over people and Cicero you
know talks about all different types of
slavery being possible you know not
everybody is going to be a slave in the
same way but they all have they all have
their origin in a kind of foolishness
the opposite of wisdom he also talks
about the fact that slaves can be
subject to other slaves you can have an
entire hierarchy of slaves within a
household and that you know this is a
very common thing to point out those on
top start to forget that they're slaves
because there's somebody down below them
that they can kick or compel or do
something to but they are just as much
slaves they are just as foolish as the
people who they're looking down on who
are below them the key thing is that
they ultimately don't do what it is that
they will they don't live in the way
that they would like to live by pursuing
things that they think to be good and
indeed to be the best good the one that
other goods should be sacrificed to they
lose hold on the genuine good you know
what is what is right what is good the
virtues those worth of things wisdom and
they lose it in losing track of that
they sort of lose themselves in this
morass of all sorts of slaves all of
them on the make all of them trying to
get something from each other and from
the world none of them actually happy
none
I'm doing what they will so for Cicero
there's a very very strong connection
between on the one hand freedom and on
the other you know and wisdom and on the
other hand slavery and foolishness